here you are at CinemaCon standing right
next to Jim Carrey I'm freaking out I'm
freaking out I don't know what I like
accidentally elbow him just like I mean
you're so young do you even remember or
Ace Ventura and he introduced you right
now let's start our interview and then
I'll introduce you I'm very excited are
you gonna be able to focus probably not
that's I'm fine I'm fine I got this
acting let's do this so I'm excited to I
guess represent the culture show the new
trailer because I don't think people got
enough of the from the first trailer but
I know how much action there is how much
tribute it
it pays to the original show and how
much Spanish there is and how like I'm
half Peruvian and the movie takes place
in Peru and that's a complete
coincidence I think sorry I'm just Jim
Isabella just wants to say hi she's your
biggest fan I'm a I'm a big fan I just
yeah I really respect your work and
that's just Dora the Explorer thank you
it's just too many enough to have too
many eyes to keep track of everybody
social media
yeah this is I'm speechless yeah okay
thank you I'm good I'm good that's fine
I know you're part I'm Dora cool like
you don't you don't have to know who I
am it's fine they saw them okay let's
get back to your your important stuff
yeah this is a different kind of jungle
you're going into the city girl you're
going into mean people you're trying
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah Dora's not he's kind of a fish out
of water experience and she's not really
sure what to do cuz she's grown up in
the jungle she's home school and she's
just very fished out of water and I love
this she's herself in literally every
situation that she's in so I think that
it has a really positive like I guess
moral message underneath it all which
you wouldn't get from the trailer you
know you wouldn't expected but there's a
yeah okay so Jeffery Wahlberg is in this
movie with you you've worked with Mark
Wahlberg and transformers did you guys
ever FaceTime and why are the Wahlberg's
like following you circling you it's a
small world but I know mark mentioned
something about wanting to be in this
movie as Swiper and I was like okay but
you have to know Spanish like give me
something to work with here you didn't
have anything now but Jeffrey's like
half Dominican and so we really relate
to each other like the mixed actor level
we're like we're not white enough to
play like Caucasian rules and we're not
like Hispanic enough to play like you
know I don't know it's just as we
this weird place to be in but um
Geoffrey's a sweetheart I love him and I
wish he was here right now I I think
he's the sweetest person ever and like
yeah we're such good friends I yeah I
just love him so much every Wahlberg
just has come from like a good just or
just come from a good tree
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]